hello can you all see me can you hurry
me can you see me hello hello hello
everybody hello hello Wow hello there
hello there
hello and once again people do not
listen when I say that I'm gonna be
right back there's a stream over Oh No
ah yes or hit pause or press the pause
button twice pause and play should get
you back hello hello hello everybody
hello
hello ok you're all back now so thank
you so much for watching and I want I
just have to say after you know they're
done there's one more donation that I'm
gonna read for you guys hello hello
hello hello well some people say I look
like the medic from tf2 more than
anything and without my glasses see
people say I look like a scout so thank
you all for keep sticking with me hello
hello hello these are just these are
just Apple earpods they're nothing
special art so anyway now that you're
all back I just want to say Brian Sugden
who has donated a lot of money and he
needs to stop because it's kind of
ridiculous
he donated 75 dollars for me I mean it's
just absolutely incredible thank you
Brian sucked in so much but that's
enough stop Brian what are you doing too
many donations stop alright so anyway we
are starting out with the next and needs
a custom story which is called oblivion
drops of wine oblivion drops of wine by
Zeke Stowe
I look like the AVGN I don't know what
that is I have no idea what that is
hello hello hello art if everybody's
ready we are good to go so let's get
started uh sounded lame
oh holy crap just as I get in the game
two more people donated thank you guys
so much you guys are just the most
amazing fans I could ever hope for and
what is going on here whoa hello sorry
my head doll most fell off my shoulders
there and it's pitch-black back out
there don't listen to you what am I not
listening to you
please dummy Kyle my head hurts
help me what why another one wait
another what did I miss one Oh boobs
whoops whoops whoops whoops whoops
whoops okay here we go let's make it
simple you just woke up and you're
probably having a headache
your name is max location London time
some play some day in April 2023 after
entering the WH en stabilizer the space
tunnel some year in the middle of the
18th century this note should be exactly
in front of you how close am i all right
I know you're in a bad mood but there's
something you need to know first of all
I'm your former self and you're a dick
in case you haven't noticed the subject
other note second of all don't be fooled
by the silent - this mansion it all
right took your life four times before
and the fact that you are reading this
means I'm also dead well that makes them
five that means you're number six I'll
stop here to give you time to comprehend
and that looks like a lot of notes from
previous selves yeah this is how the
form my phone my cell phone when I woke
up I couldn't remember anything I felt
nothing but that headache I entered the
mansion and started exploring and while
I was in one of the rooms I heard
something just outside the door when I
opened the door I would saw wall
blocking the way out so I began to smash
that wall with everything I got I was
trapped in that room for about five
hours and that gave me my memory back I
got my memory and all the memories of my
former four selves four former selves of
mine I knew what it's like to be in five
places at once
except a little deeper voice in the guy
with uh than the saffron yeah all right
interesting that music sounds familiar I
know what that's from oh here we go
flute under the rug clip hello
okay chapter 1 the mansion you'll see
strange events happening in the mansion
and those events are just us moving
around in the past you know it's time
chaos in here from my memories I saw
that there was a broom where no one
could pass three of us died there and I
promised myself to make sure you get
past it
that's why I didn't rush into that room
instead I decided to write these notes
to help you tell me by the way there was
a lantern just before you enter the
mansion checked it if it's still there
yeah we'll need it but good oh hello
there you it's really cool huh this is
actually really cool idea so many
useless candles
where oh you mean unlit candles hmm
interesting and then a wheelchair will
emerge from the darkness squeaking
slowly
I don't see you know wheelchair ah
bloody hell this Maris beware five was
trapped oh I see a door
okey-dokey I think that there was a keys
here somewhere the key unlocks the door
the room you just came by okay yeah all
right then oh man more people are
donating which you're good okay there's
an extra key in this piano really is
that how we're gonna do this smash come
on that's more like it
it's my ash oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
that's a good all right so now I got the
key okay so I got the key Wow holy hell
you guys are absolutely incredible
that's that's insane
you guys are amazing thank you so much
for the donations that's that's that's
hidden that's absolutely incredible
thank you guys so much I wish I could do
more than just play video games for you
guys but I mean it's really really
amazing after after tonight I'll take
down the donation thing because I want
to focus for the charity stream at the
end of this month and if you didn't know
we are doing a child's play charity on
the 28th on the 28th of October that is
a Sunday we're starting from like 10:00
a.m. till 10:00 p.m. so mark your
calendars for that we are going to be
doing we are gonna oh yeah this is like
that song for module
probably bad because of the whole
copyright notice thing but this is
actually probably okay it's probably
okay child play you can check out the
child play website for um what they do
but they basically provide entertainment
for kids who are who basically spend
their lives in hospitals wait wait what
seems to be kind of opening did I read
the note I just picked up huh
I didn't know that I picked up a note
did I pick up a note yeah I don't know
what happened about the wheelchair
either I just kind of nope did I oh I
can almost see this student sitting here
close to the fire and reading what
happened to all those people should I
say what happened to us okay sorry I
don't know how I miss it yeah there was
a wheelchair somewhere but that didn't
happen oh thank you is there pendragon
some under here girl can't get under
this is a dead end
alright what is the name of the mod it
is oblivion drops of wine okay got that
good to go fuel for de Lantern no no no
this stairs again
of course why is there never anything
under stairs it sounds like it's gonna
open but I don't know guess it's not
all right there we go there okay well
now what are we doing oh yeah oh wait no
that's the oil sounds open for a key I
guess I'll go upstairs
Guatemala all of Guatemala is watching
me
I guess the pressures on I better I
better say something clever um the box
within a box within a box box ception um
something clever
uh what potato huh
but potato yeah okay you got a guac
Guatemala llama or Guadalajara Guatemala
okay mmm all right there we go
got that well this is so weird there's
like every single door around here is
just locked I got that key but I that
just locked that unlike that other room
there must've been something else in
that other room that I missed America
Brazil California Ohio wait a minute
that means I'm from Ohio that means I'm
watching myself wait no we were all
staring at the fire why were all myself
staring at the fire hmm interesting
must be something in here something that
I am missing something that I will see
eventually England is watching will
Thank You England
I like your people and your tea is
delicious or something I don't know
maybe it is either way hmm
oh hang on I know what I know what I
should probably do I went into that one
room but I never bothered to turn on my
light I don't know I think I may have
forgotten that I had a lantern so there
might be something else in there that I
that I probably missed Sacramento baby
where's that door with the wall that's
where five got trapped or something so
or anything else in here that I should
know about some behind one of these
paintings baby new new aha troll come on
boo boo whoo all right yes I am happy
that I have a nominee yeah yeah I see
here man Kenny well poop the whole
underground system of a societies of
moles is watching me
ah yes Scotland Scotland is out here I
okay I never been dog you oh okay now
all of Scotland is gone I'm pretty sure
okey and never go off here do go ye
Bliley
Eileen blue hello you never gonna get a
he eh okay so anyway all of my Scottish
fans have just left the building
where can you donate there's a widget
down in the description below thank you
very much
the hell is that music okay I'm actually
confused now because I've been around
here I can't seem to find anything does
anyone have any tips what do I need to
know if anyone's gone through this one
before if anyone knows of someone who's
played this before like her oh oh
that's why oh never mind I got it
oh what's that Annika - okay Norman
alright so after years of practical
experience of trying to control negative
mass energy we finally did it
we managed enlarging a wormhole for the
quantum foam and holding it open Alan I
couldn't wait till morning I just rushed
in that was stupid of you wasn't it you
dumb butt come on what the third you
thinking about rushing in without doing
proper protocol here well what uh wait
what the hell what the quantum foam is
disentangling I'm so confused and I
think I should go that way maybe the
quantum foam is oh my god what what what
God or what the quantum foam it isn't
dangling look what a foam I don't think
I'm supposed to be here am i the quantum
foam is disentangled hey I always
breathing oh my hey what have I done
what have I done huh Giga I mean this
space in between space
I feel life all around me I am so
connected to everything now maybe I'm
supposed to throw something at that I
don't know
happy Sh Oh poo fish there we go that's
what was supposed to happen not complete
disentanglement of all the rillette
corporality x' of everything so huh-huh
what happened to me what happened
where am I oh my I just I felt like I
could experience everything all at once
okay mmm all right then shirts nice
music
I do love good classical music every
once in a while and uh okay I don't know
what quites going on here lots of
breakable stuff though now down down and
up there note here we go I've just had a
hallucination I saw a monster the size
of a building and then the ground starts
shaking and then I couldn't move and
then the monster said peek-a-boo I see
you
just kidding what Kondo kid about that
store stuff that's Bowl don't kid around
ah
peekaboo ah ah yeah yeah
all right I think I know what happened
here you think's you think's you know
well what happened mind filling me in
cuz I would like to know what a mess
alright let's go up anyway well oh come
on what the hell I'm bull honky does
pull honky alright so I'm actually kind
of confused as to what's going worth a
shot
shut up crash my ish okay so you know
what's happened here so tell me it's my
age
Oh need that my man that all Swiss all
of Swiss land is watching me
Dom
hmm jamming out to classic musical I all
of Alaska all 15 of you all 15 of yah eh
oh no that's Canada I'm actually kind of
confused grab the wine grab the wine
grass grab what wine all of the wine how
am I supposed to grab the wine oh I saw
a hand I see a hand ha ha wait no that
didn't help me at all that didn't help
me even a little bit how do I feel about
the Dutch Dutch are my favorite people
as are everybody else let's see here on
the floor
trapdoor on the floor trapdoor on the
floor trapdoor on the floor where is it
strapped to one on the floor trapdoor on
the floor cap door on the floor cut door
on the floor tap door on the floor
tap door on the floor trap trap door on
the floor to have tripped over on the
floor trap
okay follow me I tried but it couldn't
seem to open it's not it's not opening
it's it's not opening it's not easy when
I find it's gonna be completely obvious
I imagine it with me I imagine it will
be
why does my lantern keep getting turned
on in front of the wine well in front of
the wine I am looking in front of I'm
standing directly in front of the wine
messing around like a white stripe on a
zebra
mmm-hmm-hmm
look at every single bottle
looking at every single bottle I am
looking on the floor in front of the
wine is a broken bottle there as a
bottle here on the floor in front of the
wine you know you could you could be a
bit more specific
you could be just a little more specific
the whole world is watching me
no light all the candles under the
painting under the painting under the
painting under the painting under the
pink nope nope I was hiding from my
shame of being unable to solve whatever
this is there's something up there
there's something up there throw
something at the wine I'll throw
something I think mom yeah no you know
here look uh nope can't sleep on the bed
nope can't sleep ah so nobody knows how
to help me nobody's even gonna bother no
one's even gonna try no one's even gonna
do anything to help me can I smash the
floor in front of the wine what is your
obsession with the floor in front of the
wine dearly what is your obsession with
the floor in front of the wine there's
nothing on the floor in front of the
line
Oh oh woe is me I shall forever wander
the halls and my oil has run out oh woe
is me woe is me oh oh oh woe is me
oh ok anyway so let me just explore in
here for a bit
not shisha hmm why can I move the whole
table hmm mash my ash nope nip nip nip
nip nip nip nip yes everybody's going to
leave because I can't possibly solve
this puzzle I'm too stupid to solve it
I'm too stupid yup
GARP yeah yup yup yup
you're hey where are my mods hey can one
of my mods look up something can one of
my mods look up something pretty please
come on mods it's not that simple look
up another guy that has played this game
and to tell me on here lizard of guilt
go go really
yeah it's called oblivion drops of wine
the clock there's nothing to declare
there is nothing to the cloud all of
these are gone
oblivion drops of wine yeah look well
lizard of guilt has always let me down I
mean he freaking he freakin spoiled the
twenty thousand subscriber fan view did
you guys know that lizard of guilt
spoiled the surprise of the twenty
thousand subscriber video did you know
that he did he did he spoiled it and um
yeah I was supposed to get that right as
I got twenty thousand subscribers in
that didn't happen that didn't happen he
sent it to me like at nineteen thousand
some odd and some odd mmm-hmm
literate of guild are you've been
looking it up lizard are you are you are
you looking it up lizard are you are you
there's anybody looking it up nobody's
looking it up is it
nobody's looking it up nobody's looking
it up well Bethy hurry up hurry up hurry
up hmm cuz I'm just in desperation here
oh yeah yeah come on camera
no good no come on tumor culture don't
fail me now Dom oh no no hmm this isn't
like a smartness thing this is a what
the hell am I even looking for kind of
thing because he growing this rum and
you're like okay
am i what what am I supposed to do what
am I even looking for there's a ladder
that goes to a trapdoor but it's like
what what am I supposed to do about that
so it's like ah go back into the
painting hallway there is something
there the last painting on the hallway
the painting hallway you mean this one
Wow you guys can you stop typing the
answers in all caps cuz that doesn't
help me under here
aha there we are got it got it got it
got it got it got it got it got it got
it got it got it got it got it got it
got it got it
OOP OOP ah there we go got it got it got
it got it got it thank you everybody
Oh what do we have here
Oh huh let's see now mm-hmm Oh which way
do I go
towards the oil finally jump-scare
incoming well thanks for spoiling that
hello what are we out of here hmm
that wasn't so bad was it oh oh oh oh
you're getting close be careful both of
us okey-dokey
okay well now what do we have here oh
it's so nice bright and nice hmm
I still remember the Easter egg scare
from lost the lights that was
unbelievably terrible god I still have
nightmares about that one
whoa lots of supplies this is almost
never good Hey
oh boy oh my oh my what yes
oh my oh my goodness oh boy
what are they doing to me what are they
gonna do to me Julie what are they gonna
do to me oh there's so many key oh my
love down dumb goodness gracious
my word don't turn around I don't want
to turn around don't tell me that don't
tell me there's something behind me do
not tell me something like do not tell
me there's something behind me do not
tell me there's something behind me
please do not tell me something remind
me
okay all right what that what what what
what why hey I'm not going to pick all
these up I don't even have what why
people one of each I did
I tagged reads the machine room wait oh
wait no these are actually something
okay machine room key one of each I do
have to get one of each okay I got the
machine room rusty key and all right I
think I got it enough yeah I got enough
okay I got them all okay
more oil good now what's in here
okay I want to give you a very important
advice as soon as you enter that place
run sprint don't release that shift
button if you know what I mean okay
sound good buddy I don't think that does
anything does it oh this is gonna be
lovely I can't wait to see where this
heads alright
I have to tell you something
hallucinations are two types one that
can hurt you and one that can you
already saw the harmless type in the
mansion the one which was split into two
pieces really horrible face what uh uh
as for the harmful ones they look
different they're taller and
better-looking I just want to give you
heads up so that you don't have to learn
it the hard way PS arm those ones cannot
break doors and when you were close to
them they would just go poof okay all
right um okay
confused is everyone confused
I am goodness gracious I guess I'll try
these keys can I use the side of this
wake cot can I use this item this way
can I use this item this way Thanks okay
I'm supposed to what somehow flip the
levers flip the levers okay what am I
supposed to do here nope no scares in
the game so far
Wow what am I supposed to do there I
almost wait to get up here hmm hmm
this was just like all drawers full of
keys I don't see any unique type there
only wait oh hang on this type is a
different type yeah that's a different
type nope can't use that item this way
and no that's all of them that one's
kind of offset is that special probably
not oh how I am this is it the door you
see in front of you leads to the room
where no one survived so here's the plan
I'll go back and get a bottle of wine
and I'll use it to mark the shortest way
out you just follow the drops of wine
okey-dokey
alrighty then sounds good how do I get
through there there's a ladder in one of
the side rooms I saw that but it didn't
seem to be doing anything and I don't
know what those levers do let's see the
true commentator okay that's fine see
press all four levers I only saw three
we're all where's the fourth lever
where's the fourth lever where is it
where is it what is it what is it where
is it haiji be sugar where is this
so-called fourth lever I see one and
then two and then three you'll see try
pushing the levers down I want to be
able to get up there but I can't seem to
go cuz there's stuff up there that I
want to find I need to find a chair or
something or a box you have to push all
down nine I'll try all down down and
then one more
mm-hmm all right that didn't seem to
work at all
balls I can't do a livestream why can't
I why can't I do a livestream that seems
awfully it seems awfully bad all I see
are these drawers and I don't think I
can like get these to stack up I might I
might be able to but it'd be a pain in
the butt Balzac exactly someone who
understands me
big Harry oh oh here we go here we go
got it
yeah like mouth I'm so great
how on earth seriously where did all
these boxes come from covering up a hole
in the wall no okay then cheers what's
with all the boxes okay I have many keys
nope nope nope nope nope nope okay oh
boy
all right the other side's oh oh no of
course the boxes duh the boxes are here
because I need the boxes to climb up oh
man this is gonna be annoying and I hate
box stacking but here we go all right of
course I need about probably six
probably Friday just to be sure here we
go
think yeah one more one more why Mart
why not one more oh yeah there hasn't
been a single scare in this whole game
I'm actually kind of curious as to why
there's a hole in the gate wait where no
there wasn't
was there no there's no hole in the gate
oh yes there is
oh you're right there's a hole in the
gate I don't think I can get through
there though I think that's the same
type of hole that I tried to get through
before did not up nope you're right it
worked
never mind and pull it down okay so
about that down
and then uh then I got to try all of it
again Oh think allow down and um
okey-dokey I have enough hmm
well the true commentator seriously
that's not my fault
other people are doing just fine I don't
know why you want to blame me for it oh
this is where I this is where is get
serious okay
okie dokie whew okay here we go
Chapter two drops of wine yeah I don't
like this I don't like it either buddy
what oh boy I am so confused
okay ha no that guy's just a pooper
right tall guy Hoover
I don't know huh now get higher I need
to go faster okay I've got fatter now
what the hell am i starting what what
what hell a jump left yeah this is
awesome
holy crap Oh Lucien whoosh Oh like a
mouse yeah hmm this is incredible
I've never seen anything like this ha ha
whoosh yeah oh man
and a job yeah Lee Oh what I slowed down
did I just do that I'm getting tired
oh oh oh I'm on my own now oh boy don't
look back I'm not looking back no way no
way in hell OOP I'm going faster again a
little bit a little bit faster great
more steer fantastical oh man that was
that was like ridiculous fun also I've
never seen an amnesia level so big
that's kind of crazy I'm happy the fact
that it didn't lag either I love you all
too hmm
look back I don't want to look back
there nothing to see I hope I hope you
give me another section where I have to
go really fast again because that would
be freaking awesome ooh here we go Oh
nope nope no no no job get the ladder
get it yes yes nearly yeah oh yeah
this is why the mod is so highly
reviewed this is why I was curious
because it was like now I'm in the
unknown I was curious because it was
like nothing nothing seemed to be
happening to be continued hahaha yeah
boom that was awesome that was freaking
awesome I mean my goodness that was just
amazing
I was awesome I was very very very
underwhelmed
I was very underwhelmed that was what
was going on in the beginning there I
mean it really I guess if you knew if
you could get lucky and find what you
needed to do you could have gotten to
that part really quickly but then I took
this a little that's a quite a bit of
time but either way yes I will post all
all three of these custom stories up on
my youtube channel so you can watch them
later so anyway man that was just how
just bundles of fun I like that a lot I
like that a lot but anyway thank you
guys so much for watching and helping
out they so this is the end of the
livestream thank you guys so much for
watching and helping out and um it's
just it's just incredible that you guys
have donated so much to me to help me
out I mean you've already offset the
cost of my new graphics card so my next
my next thing is getting a new headset
I'm gonna get a new really really nice
headset I'm from Cincinnati and I'm
gonna get a new keyboard cuz this is
just a crappy $10 keyboard um you guys
are really helping me out cuz recently
like all of my stuff has been crashing
and I don't know why but I'm just really
happy that you guys have you been there
for me and have been willing to help me
out so big FaceTime so man thank you
guys so much and oh if you wanted to
donate I've there's been so many
donations but if you if you still do the
link is in the description below in the
little um in the UM and the what's going
to pin that's what it called there's a
chip-in widget there but you can see
people have already donated a lot of
money to me I mean it's kind of
overwhelming how much people have but
it's just it means so
much to me know that you guys actually
do care about me as a person and not
just from you know just that I'm a
youtuber of some report you know so I
hope you all enjoyed this livestream I
love doing it we'll do another one next
week I'll do three more custom stories
for you guys and I hope you guys enjoyed
I had a lot of fun playing these with
you guys trying to get through the
puzzles with your help it just it's just
an amazing thing oh let me go through
the names of the people that um that I
donate again oh Jessica Fauci donated
$100 oh man Jessica that's incredible
you are
that's absolutely astonishing thank you
so much for helping me out oh man
$5 from Zoey as a party thank you so
much Zoey god
hooray Jessica yes hey Zoey hey Thank
You Man three dollars from Michael
Rhonda Nelly oh you guys seriously you
gonna make me you don't make me lose my
mind
$80 from Daniel can thak $80 from Daniel
thank you thank you so much it's it's
completely out ready so I'm gonna go buy
a new headset and I'm gonna be a bike
the best headset that money can buy
seven point one humongous headsets gonna
make my head look like a giant and it's
just it's just amazing
what you guys are doing so thank you
Daniel and $10 from Courtney Phillips
thank you so much thank you $25 from amv
Davis that's another Amanda Davis
donated more I forget I think she
donated quite a bit before so thank you
so much for donating again Amanda you
you're just like the best guy you guys
are the best
it's crazy and I'm hoping I'm gonna I'm
gonna stop taking these donations soon
because it's just too much and I want
people to remember that we are doing a
charity livestream on yeah that's a bug
I think I crushed a bug while I was
playing that game yeah here we you you
yeah sorry to interrupt that movie but
yeah thank you guys so much for helping
out $22 from Andrew batty
Thank You Andrew thank you so much and
$10 from Jason hi done and that's the
end of the donation from now so thank
you all so much and also remember we
have a t-shirt giveaway we're giving
away ten free t-shirts of the markiplier
logo t-shirts which are available right
you can see them here
hello Guatemala yeah though there it is
that's the t-shirts if you want to get a
t-shirt for yourself or a sweatshirt as
well they're available there if you want
to like you know buy something of mine
and you know get something in return
this is kind of how I feel like I'm
gonna move forward with this so thank
you guys for helping out so much oh five
dollars another five dollars from
Michael run dinelli so thank you again
and oh man man thank you guys so much
you guys are really the best but if you
don't want to get in the raffle share
one of my ration compilations send me an
email at markiplier at gmail.com
markiplier at gmail.com with a
screenshot of the share and I'll get
your name in the raffle so thank you
guys again the raffle ends on Thursday
that's all I gotta say you guys are
really the best fans I could ever hope
for like beyond great all of you so
thank you so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye boy be here next week next week
at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time we're
doing it again bye bye